jusqu'ici le contenant en plastique que
vous placez dans votre bac de recyclage
faisait un long voyage à l'autre bout du
monde
bien souvent jusqu'en chine pendant des
années les pays riches ont envoyé des
millions de tonnes de pots de yaourt
usagers de contenants de jus de fruits
et autres bouteilles de shampoing vers
la chine pour y être recyclés des
déchets nettoyer et broyés par des
entreprises chinoises locales puis
revendus aux industriels pour être
transformé un business très lucratif
pour l'industrie chinoise
rien qu'en 2016 les importations de
plastique ont rapporté 3 7 milliards de
dollars au pays
mais dès 2017 la chine réagit et
commence à interdire l'importation de
différents types de plastiques une
décision surtout motivé par la
protection de l'environnement certains
déchets étant difficiles à recycler se
retrouvent parfois rejetées dans la
nature
l'objectif est aussi de faire
disparaître ces villages poubelles qui
sont apparus dans le paysage chinois
malgré tout d'autres déchets continuent
d'être illégalement importées en chine
le tri sélectif n'est pas encore au
point et pas assez rigoureux
le coût de la récupération et du
recyclage des déchets restent élevés
favorisant ainsi les importations
frauduleuses
conséquence de la fin des importations
de déchets par la chine les pays
exportateurs cherche de nouvelles
destinations pour les traiter pour
prendre le relais d'autres pays
asiatiques comme le vietnam la malaisie
ou encore la thaïlande mais les
capacités de recyclage dans ces pays
sont souvent limités les déchets
s'entassent dans des décharges sont
brûlés sans précaution ou finissent dans
la mer conscient du problème le vietnam
et la malaisie
réduisent déjà leurs importations de
plastique pour ne pas être submergé et
commencent déjà à renvoyer les
containers illégaux à leur expéditeur